I had colorectal resection surgery June 17th. The cathology report indicated that it was
complete, meaning that all visible cancer was removed with safe margins. However, I now have
the highest CEPA readings ever at 18 nanograms per milliliter, also by circadian
DNA, tumor cell, sanitary tests for the first test was 10 ever was 24, and I read that CEPA is often
5 months, I think post surgery, you mean, and settles down, but may not be the case if sanitary
tests is also high. Why do high scores seem to happen for many people post surgery? I had a
bloated question, but please speculate. Somebody else asked this question a few weeks ago,
two markers elevate post surgery, and I didn't quite ask, I didn't search for any research on that,
and I don't know that there actually would be research on that, maybe some old research after
tumor markers came out, first came out, what it deduced two dozen years ago, but they're just used
less and less now, because of things like this, you know, I've stated that, but my belief is that
oncologist told me it's tumor markers because they assume that you're going to do chemotherapy,
and many times when we do chemotherapy or tumor markers, they go top. So whoever tumor markers are
an enzyme that are released by different cells, not just cancer cells, so in the
active surgery, you're going to be damaging cells and tumor markers can go up. I don't know how long
they will stamp, I'm not sure about that. If you debunk this, so just think about it, if you debunk
the cancer and you're removed, all the visible cancer, and let's say you do a PET scan, and there's
nothing else hot spot in your body, so they think that there's quote-unquote no evidence of disease.
We all know that you still have cancer different places, we all do, even if you've never been diagnosed.
But it's definitely under, you know, a couple of million cells large, but that even that can still,
you know, be giving it up to a marker, enzymes and show positive to a marker, at least show, you'll have
some tumor markers. But that certainly, if that was true, if we just make those assumptions that
everybody does have some other cancers in their body outside of the primary site, surgery on the
primary site is not going to make the other sites more active. So from just a physiological understanding,
search, let's say you have colon cancer and you remove that part of the colon, you debunked it,
very clean margins, it is certainly not going to make, let's say even if you knew you had metastasis,
that in itself is not going to make the metastasis go crazy. The only danger in surgery is that,
you know, your body has to heal from the surgery and it's healing from the surgery your body makes
and it gives off more growth hormone and growth stimulating cells to heal from the wound.
Could that be a fuel to or, you know, adding gasoline on the fire of a metastatic tumor? Yes,
that could that could be, but you're taking out the bulk of the tumor, which you'd have to say,
if you had elevated tumor markers prior to surgery, the majority of it had to be coming from
that mass and removal of it. What should you think would then lower the CDA of readings?
Yeah, but prior to surgery, it was like four or five NGs per whatever milliliter and never
never was very high at all. And I met with oncologists two days ago and he said,
basically you have an active cancer going on there, so they're not even going to do a hip replacement
under those circumstances, which is another question I asked for. I was sorry to interrupt.
Yeah, so your latest PET scan showed what again?
I did, I've never had a PET scan. The last MRI showed, you know, just basically the tumor trunk from
like eight centimeters to 2.1 and that's what they removed shortly thereafter. So I haven't had a scan
since the operation. Was there any side of the testysis anyway? Nope, they did, they purposely did a
test MRI of the whole torso and stuff and they didn't find anything.
And the surgeon looked around also when she was in there and she didn't observe anything either.
Then I would just wait it out. I wouldn't be concerned about those numbers until your body settles down.
Remember, any lab you do is a clue. But things can change because of other reasons too. You had
surgery so that could throw off different markers. And there's not a lot of data on how surgery throws
on tumor markers. So we just don't know, I mean, I just know in my practice, that is a common thing.
When a person has surgery, their tumor markers spike and go up and can be up there up for several
months. It makes me think that that's just and again, like I said before, another reason why
the colleges have shied away from doing tumor work or testing because they have to sit down with
a person and explain what I'm explaining to you. Well, it can go up after this and the person's
freaking out that their cancer is spread and I thought you just got an all blah, blah, blah.
So it's easier not to do the test if it's going to give you false positives. So if the test is for
and shows elevation, showing and that equates to increased cancer growth,
that elevation post surgery that doesn't equal increased cancer risk would be a false positive. So
I would I would wait it out, let your body flush that out. And the only concern I have is that the
signatory CT DNA is triggered off of the actual DNA from whatever they biopsied or took out
during from the pathology after surgery. And that supposedly has a very short half-life. So
if you find some of that, maybe that indicates that something's out there in your body somewhere.
So that's the one that scares me a little more, be honest. And I think if you're concerned about
I think the next test would be a password.